when you walk into the office the
factory or wherever you work you expect
certain things how people speak to you
how your boss behaves how you're made to
feel
and some of the country's biggest
employers have faced hard questions
recently about allegations of bad
behavior on their watch
claims of sexual harassment from female
staff at the CBI one of Britain's
biggest business groups the Tesco
chairman John Allen standing down over
sexual misconduct allegations although
he says he is determined to prove his
innocence
then there was Dominic Robb no longer
Deputy Prime Minister after a report
found he was quote persistently
aggressive in meetings
and after Phillip Schofield quit itvs
this morning over his quote unwise but
not illegal relationship with a younger
male colleague he has had to deny
bullying claims too and so has his
program editor Martin Frizzell is there
a toxic work environment at this morning
I'll tell you what's toxic I've always
found toxic is aubergine do you like
aubergine
that's him avoiding questions from Sky
News about allegations of toxic behavior
on set do you is there a toxic work do
you like aubergine because I don't like
aubergine it's just a personal thing
he's been outrageously dismissive and
flippant on camera about an immensely
serious issue
never before has how we're treated at
work been talked about so much
I'm Kimberly Leonard and this is the Sky
News Daily
in a minute I'll be asking a legal
training expert why we're hearing more
about toxic workplace culture at the
moment but first Francis fry I'm an
operations management Professor which
means I'm good at getting to the root
cause of problems and my mindset is
everything is fixable Francis was a
professor at Harvard Business School
when she got a call from Uber in 2017.
the company was in the middle of a very
public crisis and they needed her help
to fix it and so when I got there and
there was you know the Riders were upset
the drivers were upset the employees
were upset the shareholders the regular
I mean everyone was upset I knew that
there had to be a root cause to that
problem and by what I read I had a
hypothesis that trust was probably being
broken at lots of levels Uber's toxic
workplace culture was first exposed in a
blog post that was published by a former
employee it detailed allegations of
sexism and harassment and it went viral
that was just the tip of the iceberg
a U.S federal investigation was launched
and the company was eventually forced to
pay out almost three and a half million
pounds to employees who were sexually
harassed at work
now Francis that first complaint really
opened the floodgates didn't it how many
people at Uber then came forward with
their own complaints at the time oh my
gosh so many complaints like maybe maybe
a thousand complaints which is first of
all I just I want to thank everyone who
complained because it's only when people
complain that we can see it in the data
that we have a chance of fixing it so
I'm I remain grateful to everyone that
complained and all those complaints what
what kind of complaints were you dealing
with when we looked at all of the
complaints and there were of many shapes
and sizes but there was one strong
throughput which is that they almost all
of them like 95 of them described an
interaction between an employee and
their manager whether it was a front
line manager or the most senior manager
in the organization and so that told us
where to look and it was in the
interactions of managers and when we saw
the complaints we were like goodness
a lot of these managers they're either
bad people or they haven't been taught
how to manage so what were some of the
things that you're trying to deal with
very simple things like how to give
feedback so at Uber it had become a bit
of a competitive sport to give feedback
in a way that really felt brutal to
people so they hadn't used positive
reinforcement very much and I know as an
academic that sincere and specific
positive reinforcement is far more
powerful than constructive advice but
nobody had ever taught them that so they
thought their job was to just keep
giving piercing constructive advice that
was making people's satisfaction go down
people were scared they stopped trying
to you know innovate because they didn't
want to get in trouble so I think it was
those sorts of things and then when any
sensitive issues came up like
interpersonal when when we're dealing
with real life people it was handled
enormously clumsy like just you would
not have wanted your children to be the
ones that were bringing up sensitive
topics and it was in the hands of
uneducated clumsy people it turned out
they weren't bad people they just had
never been taught and I quickly
understood why they hadn't been taught
they would get hired as an individual
contributor do a good job and very soon
after be promoted to manager and then
very soon after be promoted to a manager
of managers because the company was
growing so fast in retrospect I'm sure
the company would have layered on
education as they grew as opposed to
having to come in and do it after the
crisis
[Music]
we've heard just how bad the culture can
become in workplaces and we'll come back
to what can be done about it in a minute
but let's talk more about how companies
are dealing with this nehalug is a
senior trainer at the law firm Lewis
silkin we've had so many high profile
examples of bad behavior at work
recently a lot of companies now looking
inwards why do you think the issues like
bullying harassment toxic workplaces
have come under such scrutiny lately so
I think there's lots of different
reasons and perhaps maybe the starting
point is we're really having a think
about acceptable workplace conduct what
that really looks like and yet you're
right we haven't really seen it leave
the headlines in in what feels like
years now and I think the foundation for
acceptable workplace conduct is really
that our Behavior and those everyday
kind of workplace interactions that make
up our culture whether they're in person
or virtual we need to be ensuring that
they're safe respectful and create sort
of an inclusive culture for all we live
in a very diverse society and those
different personal characteristics about
you know they're interplaying at work we
have different beliefs we have different
religions different
different cultures different protected
beliefs and we've seen that a lot come
at recently come into a scrutiny when we
look at gender identity and gender
critical beliefs but with that greater
diversity comes greater challenge at
work and how we demonstrate respect for
other people's views and opinions and we
really know that how we see that changes
over time
we have maybe four or five generations
interacting together in the workplace so
colleagues need to understand how
workplace values and attitudes have
moved and shifted and that can create
friction and again that's why we're
seeing so much of this it's a topic of
conversation at the moment it's
interesting when you say there's
Generations different Generations all
together in the workplace when you look
at how things have changed over time how
do you think workplace standards have
changed over time yeah I mean it's
interesting the standards of workplace
Behavior are really evolving you know at
PACE and I would say especially so in
more recent years so I started my legal
career around 15 years ago and in that
time I've seen so much change I'd say
both in terms of employer
responsibilities but equally in terms of
employee expectations so what's driving
that change well I think for me it's
sort of three key drivers so first
really prominent Global movement so we
know that the black lives matter
movement and the metoo movement have
created this fundamental shift in
creating sort of global change in that
conversation around
workplace standards and in an inequities
that exist in our societies and
employers have been very much compelled
to take a stance on those inequalities
inequities in the workplace so secondly
I think around employee expectations
employees now more than ever they want
to work for an organization that
reflects their values so we're seeing an
increasing number of employees sort of
pursuing what we call Value driven
purpose-driven employment where if their
workplace the behaviors that they see at
work don't align with their values
employees are voting with their feet so
Employers in this kind of really
competitive market to attract and retain
Talent are having to respond and I think
the third key driver of change really is
around covid that has played a huge role
in shaping our working lives
I think there was an Inc sort of
increased understanding of individuals
personal lives and before we perhaps had
this kind of workers work home is home
this sort of delineation but I think all
of a sudden with covet we started
understanding what was going on for
people and how those workplace
interactions those workplace pressures
and how we showed up for other people
really mattered so you know covert had
people kind of reevaluating what matters
to them personal health physical mental
well-being and I think employers are
really having to respond by creating
environments that are inclusive that
demonstrate safe respectful and and
inclusive behaviors and I think that's
been a real you know driver for change
okay so the idea of misconduct and
harassment versus you know a tough boss
or it's just a high pressure workplace
it can be a bit blurry sometimes so how
do you know and perhaps you can explain
what is acceptable and what the legal
definitions are and is an HR issue
different to a legal issue at work
that's a great question and I think with
these evolving standards of workplace
Behavior workplace conduct I think
that's a really tough scope to Define
and we know that some of those
unacceptable behaviors so as you say
discrimination harassment sexual
harassment victimization we know that
those unacceptable behaviors are sort of
set out in the law but there are lots of
different types of behaviors that we
think and we see to be unacceptable at
work that aren't necessarily in the law
and a good example as you say is is
bullying so in the UK there's no legal
definition of bullying so you know what
are those behaviors that we think of
that could constitute bullying well we
saw that in Dominic Robb's sort of
report recently
there was behavior that was intimidating
assistively aggressive undermining
humiliating
so we saw there were allegations around
sort of abuse of power
um you know and that issue around senior
roles and interacting across different
levels of seniority can create challenge
but where where possible I think that
managers line managers people managers
have such a strong role to play in
creating the right culture demonstrating
the right behaviors and making sure that
what they do and how they demonstrate
that to their teams is really setting an
example and data from the cipd recently
showed that when you have a toxic
workplace culture and when you have
poor Behavior at a senior level that's
often replicated by the junior staff so
a recognition that people managers and
those at senior level have a really
strong role to play yes but
interestingly Dominic Robb's response to
the report findings from his bullying
allegations was to say the threshold for
bullying was too low and of course we
heard from the editor of itvs this
morning earlier his aubergine comments
have been heavily criticized as flippant
Francis fry let's come back to you do
you think it's a management style that
determines workplace culture both at
Uber and more generally and if that is
the case then who is to blame is it
individuals who set the tone for that
management style or is it systemic so
it's systemic I mean there's always
individuals that need to be separated
because they're like a source of lots of
troubles but I in every culture that
I've gone into it's systemic and it's
not system it wasn't designed to be
harmful but we didn't understand the 360
degree view around it so when people
were growing and promoting it was lauded
as an awesome organization that promoted
from within and it just didn't have
enough peripheral vision to understand
the damage it was doing I think today
everybody gets to look at the very
public situation that Uber had and it's
far less likely that people are going to
have managers be promoted without
teaching them their job which is how to
manage so what about employees who are
stuck in oh yeah these toxic workplaces
if that internal system is broken it's
very difficult for them
to even come forward with a complaint
you know you said thanks a lot to
everyone who complained but if they're
in a system where it's so hard to
complain what should they do yeah so my
advice would be to complain anonymously
almost every organization today has an
anonymous complaint line and if you feel
like it's too risky to
um and encourage other people to
complain when we have it in the data
then when somebody looks at it they get
to see it like when we looked at the
Thousand complaints it was immediately
clear what needed to happen so I would
say one do it anonymously if you don't
feel comfortable doing a person and do
it in groups
so employees have a lot of power if they
go together as we say I suppose in some
instances places are so toxic and
the management don't want to change that
inevitably people end up leaving
oh yeah so listen if management doesn't
want to change I would not encourage
people to stay the only obstacle we've
ever seen to overcoming transforming
completely transforming a toxic culture
is the desire to change so if that
desire isn't there if there's not a
willingness to do it each person if you
have an option I would invite you to go
to a place where you don't have to
endure that but if management wants to
change
in our experience meaningful change
happens very rapidly in fact meaningful
change must happen rapidly and so as
soon as we set out on it we were able to
fix the culture very very quickly and I
would argue if we had tried to take a
long time we wouldn't have been nearly
as successful because if you take a long
time you're sending mixed messages to
people ah we see your problem but it's
really not important enough for us to
put it at the top of our priority list
so when convenient we'll put it at the
top of our priority list but we're going
to go about business as usual when we
see people being harmed our response
needs to be urgent
my thanks to Francis fry and nehalog
this episode of Sky News Daily was
produced by Sydney Pete with Alex Eden
and Rosie Gillett the editor is Philly
Beaumont
I'm Kimberly Leonard see you next time
from Sky News podcasts people treat it
as a joke a juicy bit of Gossip after
the Scandal which ultimately brought
down a prime minister Mr Pinscher what
exactly happened in the Carlton club we
take you inside the corridors of power I
felt someone grabbed my ass and I turned
around and this guy was just like
looking right at me you know basically
if it's not full and rape it's okay to
hear the stories that people have been
and still are afraid to tell you know
some of the most dangerous people are
probably the last people that you'd ever
suspect and why those accused often face
no consequences they're relying on you
not fighting the machine in a way my
biggest fear is if I don't speak out
he's going to be around forevermore
the Open Secret wherever you get your
podcasts
[Music]